it's easy to forget that a country so
rich in history like italy
is a nation younger than the united
states italy as we know it today became
a unified state only in 1861
following decades of struggle at the
forefront of many of those fights you
would be sure to find
today's protagonist general guiseppe
garibaldi
general garibaldi cut a distinctive
figure amongst the protagonists of that
epic novel that is european history of
the 19th century when
nations were forged in iron in blood but
also
in golden deception with his enviable
beard his tuscan cigars argentine
ponchos his
trusty saber and sixth shooter garibaldi
had become
one of the most popular men in the world
so much so that his men accepted
autographed photos
as a salary today we are going to look
at his revolutionary and military career
especially
at the most famous expedition of the
thousand which led to the unification of
italy this is also the story of a
natural-born
soldier and a natural leader of soldiers
who became a general with little formal
training
only direct experience of fighting to
put it in his own words
the use of the sword i learnt by
defending my own head
and in giving my best endeavors to split
those of others
was born on the 4th of july 1807 in nice
now in france but back then a part of
the
kingdom of piedmont sardinia this is one
of the many states that the italian
peninsula had been divided into
for centuries northeastern italy was
part of the austrian empire which also
controlled indirectly
other small duchies from tuscany to the
adriatic coast central italy was a part
of the state of the church ruled by the
pope and the south was ruled by the
bourbon dynasty tied to both austria and
to spain
youngest hebei's family lived off the
sea they were fishermen and coastal
traders garibaldi also had close ties
with the sea
spending most of his spare time swimming
and sailing he enlisted as a merchant
sailor at a very young age and sailed
across the mediterranean
and the black sea it was during a voyage
to russia that he became acquainted with
some members of the young italy movement
the young italy was a revolutionary
organization with ties to secret
societies led by
republican activist giuseppe mazzini
mazzini had instigated or participated
in many attempts to overthrow the rulers
of the italian governments and was now
living in exile in london
garibaldi was fascinated with mazzini's
ideals and pledged allegiance to the
young italy and their affiliated secret
organization the carbonari the aim of
these societies was to unify the italian
people under a single
democratic republican government in 1833
garibaldi enlisted as an officer in the
navy of piedmont sardinia
the following year instructed by mazzini
he instigated a mutiny intended to spark
a wider revolution and install
a republic in piemon the plan failed
miserably
and he barely escaped capture crossing
the border to france and hiding in
marseille for some time
yet according to rumors on the day that
he left he still found the time to make
love to three different women which may
be true or it may be an early indication
that he was very good at propping up his
own image
[Music]
physical prowess aside young garibaldi
had a thirst for adventure
in 1836 he set sail for south america
and like che guevara one century earlier
he looked for libertarian causes that he
could serve he found one in brazil where
he joined the separatist republic of rio
grande de soul
so how did he serve their cause well as
a pirate
or a corsair more precisely his job was
to prey
on brazilian shipping to harass their
supply lines and support the republic
during these adventures he fell in love
with and married a woman anna maria
riviero de silva better known
as anita who would remain by his side
even in battle
the war with brazil it was doomed to
fail and garibaldi was
discharged from rio grande in 1840. he
was compensated for his services with a
herd of cattle which he drove to
montevideo in uruguay
with anita and their son manatee in 1842
he joined another war of liberation that
of uruguay against juan manuel de rosas
the
dictator of argentina initially he was
put in charge of the uruguayan navy but
in 1843 garibaldi took command of a
newly formed italian legion composed of
exiles and libertarians like him
looking for cheap cloth for their
uniforms he stumbled upon a bargain
red shirts used by abattoir workers from
then on his troops would wear the
distinctive tunics and
would be known as red shirts garibaldi's
fame grew not only in the americas but
also in europe this was cemented by
victories he achieved in 1846 most
notably at the battle
of san antonio in this engagement he
first adopted his trademark tactic he
would establish a defensive line
absorb the impact of the enemy's frontal
attack and then outmaneuver it by
launching a surprise counter-attack on
its flanks
often by means of a bayonet charge his
south american experiences
gave him invaluable training in the
techniques of guerrilla warfare that he
would later use against traditional
european armies he had now acquired the
reputation of a professional rebel
an indomitable activist for the causes
of independence and republican rule
[Music]
in april of 1848 garibaldi anita and
their children sailed back to italy on a
ship called
sparranza this means hope in italian
mazzini had invited him to return to
europe to join another war
a popular revolt had ousted the
austrians from milan the king of pmos
charles albert had
taken the occasion to declare war on
austria to aid the italian rebels this
was the first war of italian
independence
mazzini saw the occasion to infiltrate
the struggle to
further his republican agenda garibaldi
entered the fight against the austrians
with
a force of irregular volunteers despite
his victories the pimontes army had been
defeated at custoza and signed an
armistice
outnumbered garibaldi dissolved his
units and evaded capture by the
austrians by
escaping to switzerland the opportunity
for another fight presented itself at
the end of 1848 in rome
pope pius ix had gained fame as a rather
liberal ruler giving hope to italian
patriots that he may be willing to lead
a federation of italian states under him
but in 1848 he revoked any liberal
reform he had
instituted in the state of the church
mazzini and the young italy then
staged a revolt which drove the pope
from rome and
installed a republic in february 1849
garibaldi had joined the roman republic
and was ready to defend it by any means
in april 1849 newly elected french
president louis napoleon later napoleon
iii
sent an army to rome to restore order as
a means to
gain the favor of the catholic
electorate a contingent under general
picard attempted to seize the geniculum
hill
they were expecting to be welcomed with
open arms by the god-fearing romans but
instead they found garibaldi the general
put up a stiff resistance
stalling the advance picard and then he
replicated his tactic
of san antonio the french were taken by
surprise and retreated hastily
leaving almost 300 dead and prisoners
behind
in may he defeated an army sent by the
king of naples and in june he was
leading the defense of rome against
another
french siege but there was no chance of
holding the city
and the republic collapsed in july of
1849 garibaldi and anita were on the run
from the french and the austrians
while in hiding anita contracted malaria
and died
in giuseppe's arms this time garibaldi
first fled to tangiers and then to new
york where for a time he worked in a
candle factory with antonio mucci
arguably
the inventor of the telephone in 1852
and 1853 garibaldi had returned to a
life of sailing he was now
a merchant ship captain transporting
guano that's bird or bat excrement
from peru to china only in 1854 was he
allowed to return to italy having
collected a family inheritance garibaldi
was able to buy a part of the small
island of caprera off the sardinian
coast which
remained his home for the rest of his
life
it was the 2nd of march 1859 and
garibaldi was milking a cow in his
caprera farm when he received a surprise
visitor
a pimontes officer envoy of prime
minister
camille benso count of cavor cavall was
a skilled politician who had been
engineering big plans for the kingdom of
pima
when the war of crimea broke out in
october of 1859 he had convinced king
victor emmanuel ii
to join the allied side against the
russian empire cavalr's only interest
was to have a seat at the peace
negotiations in march of 1856.
cavort took the occasion to approach
napoleon iii and
bring his attention to the plight of
italian citizens under the rule of the
austrians and their allies
he completed his seduction of napoleon
iii with the help of his own cousin the
countess of virginia castelloni
who actually physically seduced the
lusty french emperor
drawing him closer to the italian cause
napoleon iii and victor emmanuel ii
signed a secret treaty by which france
committed to intervene
in a war against the austrians should
they attack bimon
cavor was preparing a trap to lure
austria into war and
thought that he could make good use of
garibaldi following the envoy garibaldi
met victor emanuel ii
in turin these two were polar opposites
ideologically but
they immediately clicked bonding over
their shared love of hunting combat
and women the king offered garibaldi a
formal commission as
general in the piedmontese army in
charge of the hunters of the alps a
voluntary corps specialized in mountain
warfare
now garibaldi cavaur and the king may
have had common enemies
but not common goals garibaldi's aim was
the unification of italy if possible a
republican italy
kevor's plans were to extend the
territory and power of piemon
and the ruling house of savoy in the
first months of 1859 kavor set the stage
he started amassing troops on the border
with the austrian empire he also
encouraged italians under austrian rule
to
flee to pimor where they would join
garibaldi's hunters on the 23rd of april
the austrians
fell into the trap they issued an
ultimatum for demobilization which was
refused the second war of italian
independence it was declared
and the joint franco piedmonte's forces
sprang into action
garibaldi and his three thousand
volunteers they were outnumbered and
outgunned but he managed to score
important victories in the lombard alps
in may he defeated a larger force at the
battle of verace by using his signature
tactic
over the following weeks he captured the
cities of coma bracia
and bergamo by july he was about to
march into the trentino region when he
received urgent orders to halt the
advance
and return to turin unbeknownst to him
on the 11th of july napoleon iii had
agreed a secret armistice with
austrian emperor franz josef horrified
by the huge loss of life at the battle
of sulfurino the french
emperor wanted to cease hostilities when
the piedmontese were
informed they had no choice but to stop
fighting as the austrians would
outnumber them
more than two to one the outcome of the
war was positive to the king
and cavor they had expanded into
lombardy annexing
milan and other important industrial
areas at the same time they had annexed
other smaller independent states in the
north the kingdom
of pimon now controlled roughly
one-third of italian territory
on the other hand garibaldi was deeply
disappointed and not only because of the
secret armistice he had also found out
that as compensation for the french
intervention cavor had ceded the city of
nice to napoleon iii
paradoxically the hometown of the
champion of italian unification
was now a part of france
[Music]
garibaldi had a further disappointment
in january of 1860
on a more personal level on the 24th he
married his young fiance countess
guseppina romonde immediately after the
ceremony the general received a
mysterious note upon reading it
he snarled at the bride i thought i had
married a countess
not a [ __ ] apparently gee subpoena had
been seeing other younger men in the
past
months and was in fact five months
pregnant garibaldi had the marriage
immediately annulled the general
returned once more to his beloved
caprera to
lick his wounds but news from sicily
would lead him to unsheath his saber
once more in april 1860 a revolt broke
out
in palermo the southern half of the
italian peninsula was ruled by king
francis ii
of the house of bourbon with ties to
austria and spain the mormons had a
history of repressing revolutionary
outbreaks especially in sicily they
succeeded also on this occasion but the
result had inspired garibaldi to do the
unthinkable he raised a volunteer force
with plans to invade sicily cross the
messiness straits to the mainland
and fight his way up the boot conquering
nables and perhaps even rome
this would mean finally unifying italy
into a single state
at this stage he realized that a
republican italy was a far-fetched dream
and he was content with it being a
monarchy under victor emmanuel ii
on the night between the 5th and the 6th
of may general garibaldi
launched the expedition of the thousand
which would cement his status as a
legendary icon
in europe and america with a force of
roughly a thousand volunteers aged 11 to
garibaldi borrowed two steamers and set
sail for sicily the official version of
the story goes that victor emmanuel ii
and kvor who outwardly condemned this
adventure
secretly hoped that it would succeed in
reality cavaur
did something more than just hope the
mastermind from
turin had arranged for some piedmontese
officers and soldiers to join the
thousands
officially they were deserters but this
was just a ploy to sustain plausible
deniability he then arranged for a
garrison commander in tuscany to provide
garibaldi with
weapons and ammunition again the
official version was that these were
stolen
and what about those requisition
steamers well they were also a covert
donation from the piedmontese government
cavor had also arranged secret meetings
with british freemasons as a
conduit to secure london's approval and
support of the whole operation
the british empire had an economic
interest in causing the demise of the
bourbon kingdom and that's gaining
control of the sulphur mines in sicily
on the 11th of may 1860 garibaldi and
his thousand landed in masala western
sicily the harbor defenses responded
with a weak bombardment this was to
avoid harming the two neutral british
vessels which
by total coincidence were in the port to
stock up
on masala wine on the 15th of may
garibaldi's redshirts had their first
pitch
battle against the neapolitan troops in
kalataphimi the bourbons had
gained the upper ground and the
thousands had to fight an uphill
struggle
literally with no artillery or cavalry
support garibaldi's second in command
nino bixio suggested
a retreat to which the general replied
today either we make italy
or we die he was then immediately hit by
a rock that did not kill his moment
though garibaldi interpreted this as the
neapolitans being out of ammo so he
charged headlong up the kalataphimi hill
followed by his men
the enemies were routed in the thousands
soon became thousands as
sicilian volunteers joined their ranks
on the 20th of june the redshirts
conquered palermo
alexander dumas the writer of the three
musketeers at this point
joined the thousand he would later
co-author and edit
the general's autobiography by mid-july
the last neapolitan division
in sicily was preparing for a siege in
messina opposite
the tip of the boot as garibaldi
approached the city the bourbon
commander sent a detachment of 2
500 men to block his way in the
fortified town
of milazzo things got sticky as the
enemy commander played a garibaldi on
garibaldi that is he
stalled the attack with well-placed
sniper and artillery fire from
behind the walls of malazzo and then
launched a sudden flanking
counter-attack
but with cavalry the cavalry charge
surrounded garibaldi and his staff and
almost succeeded in capturing him but
the general sabre drawn
cut and slashed his way out of the
encirclement
milazzo and messina fell and by august
the redshirts had
reached the mainland as they marched
upwards neapolitan resistance it melted
away
marred by poor morale and possibly by
cavour's tactic of
bribing some of their generals on the
1st of october the bourbons staged their
last resistance with the battle of the
voltano river
the largest of garibaldi's career also
on this occasion he risked capture or
death as his carriage was riddled with
gunfire by a neapolitan patrol
also on this occasion the general drew
his saber and
hacked at the assailants before
rejoining the main battle the battle it
was another victory for the red
shirts in the meanwhile the piedmontese
army had descended from the north
conquering the eastern side of the state
of church in central italy on the 15th
of october the piemonte's army led by
victor emmanuel himself
met with garibaldi's forces in a town
called tiano this was cavaur's idea of
course the plan was to join up with
garibaldi's conquests in northern italy
to achieve unification
and at the same time it'd prevent
garibaldi from attacking rome and
the french garrison still protecting the
pope cavall was expecting a violent
clash but it took
only a veiled threat from the king to
avoid that your troops
a tired general mine are fresh it is my
turn now
and garibaldi handed over his conquest
to the king on the 17th of march 1861
the kingdom of italy was finally
declared the unification was not an easy
process
some southern italians did not take
kindly to the pemonization of their
lands and
launched a 10-year civil war which was
for decades covered up as a
series of large-scale police operations
against bandits or brigands but
well that's a story for another day back
to november 1860
on the 9th garibaldi set sail for
caprera once again as his vessel exited
the harbour british warships fired a
salvo in
salute to the man who had risked more
than anyone to unify italy the guns of
the pimontes fleet
they remained silent
giuseppe garibaldi resumed a simple life
in his beloved caprera
cenatus the ancient roman general he was
content with a few simple supplies
as a reward stock fish seeds and a large
box of pasta
his exploits in southern italy did not
go unnoticed in the u.s
on the 3rd of december 1860 abolitionist
frederick douglass declared in a speech
that
should the south secede i believe a
garibaldi would arise who would march
into those states with a thousand men
and summon to his standard 60 000 if
necessary
to accomplish the freedom of the slave
this may have been an inspiration for
abraham lincoln who in 1861
offered general garibaldi a commission
in the union army
it has been evaluated that his
aggressive tactics may have led to a
quicker end to the civil war
but of course this didn't happen
garibaldi was keen to accept on the
condition that the abolition of slavery
was formalized as a key war aim for the
union
even if lincoln agreed in principle he
was not ready at that stage to
make such a declaration and garibaldi
eventually declined
aged 55 riddled with old wounds and
rheumatism
the general still had some fight left in
him in 1862 he assembled another army to
capture rome but
he was stopped by the regular italian
army garibaldi ordered his men
not to shoot against fellow italians but
a skirmish ensued
and he was shot in the foot the defeat
did not dent his popularity
in fact in 1864 he visited london where
he was welcomed
triumphantly a journalist at the time
wrote respect for truth renders it
necessary to say that the
female portion of those present were
even more eager than their male
companions to reach garibaldi
now victorian in 1866 the young kingdom
of italy sided with pressure against
austria
in what was called the six weeks war aka
the third war of italian independence
despite the embarrassment of the 1862
debacle garibaldi agreed to take
charge again of the hunters of the alps
the italian army made little progress on
land losing
costosa while its navy suffered a
crushing defeat at lisa
only the prussian allies and the hunters
scored victories on the austrians
in a repeat of the previous war of
independence garibaldi's men were about
to seize trentino when he received an
order to halt
the austrians had signed an armistice
and handed over the venetia region the
general replied to the order with a
single word telegram
obadisco meaning aya bay trentino would
be contested for 50 years and was
annexed by italy
only after world war one the following
year now 60 garibaldi clearly thought
some more fighting would do good to his
aching joints his target
was roam again this time the italian
army did not manage to intercept him but
he and his men clashed with the french
near rome
the french army was equipped with the
new chasopo rifles these guaranteed a
much higher rate of fire and quicker
reload making the bayonet charges of the
red shirts rather futile the expedition
it was a disaster once again garibaldi
retreated to his island
it looked as though he would retire but
1870 brought along
another occasion for a righteous fight
towards the end of the franco-prussian
war napoleon iii's rule had collapsed
and the empire had been replaced by the
paris commune and the
so-called third republic with no ill
will against the french the old general
would fight alongside the young republic
he corralled an army of volunteers and
engaged the prussians in the vajra
region amidst the catastrophe of the
franco-prussian war the army of the voja
was
one of the few french units capable of
scoring victories against the invaders
but it was too little too late the
french defeat had a silver lining for
the italians though
in september of 1870 the garrison
protecting rome was
recalled back to serve in france taking
advantage italian troops easily marched
into the eternal city say for trentino
and the region of trieste italy
as we know it today was finally unified
after years of battles adventures
victories and defeats general garibaldi
had finally settled
he spent his retirement years in caprara
tending to his land
he received a lot of fan mail although
it was not stamped so he had to pay
hundreds of liras in fines
in 1880 he married for the third time
with francesca armasino
in his last years garibaldi founded the
league of democracy which
advocated universal suffrage female
emancipation the abolition of
ecclesiastical property
and a standing army for national unity
he also voiced his support for the
creation of a european federation which
would be led in the future
by greater germany garibaldi died on the
2nd of june 1882 at the age of 75.
he wished to have a simple cremation
though he was buried by his farm
on the island of caprera giuseppe
garibaldi is nowadays regarded by most
italians and
non-italians as a selfless hero a
brilliant military leader the true
driving force behind the unification of
italy as well as many other liberal
causes however
all heroes are men and no man is without
blemish
some revisionist historians argue that
his exploits in southern italy were just
a colonial war
disguised by lofty ideals garibaldi had
in fact promised a
land reform to the sicilian peasants but
he did not act on it
instead he ordered a violent repression
of a peasant revolt to
protect british interests at best he had
been an unwitting puppet in the hands of
kevor
the british and the freemasons one who
had caused the destruction of the south
and
the violence of the 1861-1871 civil war
other sources claimed that in the years
spent sailing the pacific he had to let
go of his ideals participating in the
trade of chinese slaves for the guano
industry according to
this version this is how he raised the
funds to purchase caprea
not for an inheritance the truth as in
many cases is open to interpretation and
even 150 years after the events
politics can influence the way that
facts are interpreted but whatever the
truth
or lack of truth garibaldi's
achievements are undeniable
this is a man who fought and risked his
life well into his 60s
a man who allowed progressive ideals to
flourish
a man who united a country so i really
hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below and don't
forget to subscribe we've got brand new
videos just like this
four times a week also i've got some
older videos from the archives linked to
on the screen now so please do check
those out
if you think you'd be interested in
those and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]
you